foreign
and it's usually trotted out as the
example in the 20th century of like okay
but you know we had penicillin like what
why that was huge and we obviously can't
afford another another Spanish flu and
uh and
um
here's the thinking and I will walk
through a little bit of um
walk through a little bit of what
gatomolo says and then go to the paper
that he's he's citing here
apparently aspirin which was a
relatively new drug at the time and
seemed like a wonder drug
uh and but not much was known about the
dosing and high dosages of course now
are understood to be toxic aspirin was a
primary drug used in the treatment of
Spanish flu
Ashley in the military
and
specifically Spanish Flu was
preferentially treated in many areas
with doses of aspirin between 8 and 31
grams per day 8 and 31 grams per day
today most aspirin is at 325 milligrams
it's a third of a gram
and the max dose recommended this is
from a 1977 FDA guideline I don't know
if the FDA ever made sense but it made
more sense then than it does now uh
presumably uh 1977 FDA guidelines they
said you know what about 4 000
milligrams about four grams per day is
really as much as you can safely take
and toxic dose is now understood to be
about 200 to 300 milligrams per kilogram
of weight which is about 20 grams per
day for 180 pound person
so reminder that the treatment for
Spanish Flu in many areas was between 8
and 31 grams per day where the toxic
dose of aspirin is now interested to be
about 20 for a 180 pound person
yeah
um you know they don't the word lethal
isn't used as I'm being a little squidgy
with my language because I couldn't find
I couldn't find the precise language I
was looking for but um but yes I think
so
um
it's got them all rights in this piece
this is why incredible caution should be
exercised around large departures from
tested and true medical practice and new
Pharma modalities and products aspirin
in 1918 was a new product relatively new
product
and um his primary source is
this uh this paper called by a woman
named starko from 2009 called
salicylates and pandemic influenza
mortality
1918-1919 pharmacology pathology and
historic evidence it was published in
clinical infectious diseases
and it is presented as a hypothesis
which is um pretty pretty fantastic and
if you want to show my screen I just
have a couple little sections to read
from this paper so again this is this is
published as a hypothesis it's published
under
um the title viewpoints Again by by an
MD who appears to be an independent
researcher
in which she argues that it was indeed
the widespread use of aspirin as a
treatment for Spanish Flu which actually
explains the mortality rate for Spanish
Flu here's a couple of quotes and sorry
this is going to jump around I'm going
to try to scroll slowly so I can show it
to you okay here we go I
sorry guys
um
this one first a Confluence of events
created a perfect storm for widespread
salicylate aspirin toxicity the loss of
Bayer's patent on aspirin February 1917
allowed many manufacturers into the
lucrative aspirin Market official
recommendations for aspirin therapy at
toxic doses were preceded by ignorance
of the unusual non-linear kinetics of
salicylate which were unknown until the
1960s which predisposed to accumulation
and toxicity
tins and bottles that contain no
warnings and few instructions and fear
of Spanish influenza and illness that
had been spreading like wildfire so
those are some of the
um we're going to stay on this for a
little bit those are some of the reasons
that she thinks we had a perfect storm
uh in 1918 for Spanish Flu to get
treated so aggressively and so wrongly
and dangerously and tragically as as the
hypothesis goes with for Spanish flu
four lines of evidence support the role
of salicylate intoxication in 1918
influenza mortality
pharmacokinetics mechanism of action
pathology and the Spate of official
recommendations for toxic regimens of
aspirin immediately before the October
1918 death Spike so I'm not going to go
through all of those all of those lines
of evidence but there's just one more
little piece I want to read to you I
think on just this the title of this
section here
aspirin advertisements in August 1918
and a series of official recommendations
for aspirin and September and early
October preceded the death Spike of
October 1918.
and so you have much like you do with
covet where
um you know the the the big spikes after
um the MRNA vaccines were introduced the
big spikes right as people were rushing
to get these these treatments which they
thought would free them from the fear
that had been inculcated in them in this
case you had a blitz campaign to
um to encourage everyone to buy aspirins
retreat with Aspirin doctors were giving
it between 8 and 31 grams per day when
20 grams per day is now known to be a
potentially lethal dose and
um and people were able to buy it over
the counter uh in
um I'm actually not sure about that but
people were able to get it much more
freely than they had before because it
was no longer under patent
which um it makes sense with the
pathology that was observed with Spanish
Flu where the dead had lungs that were
saturated soaking wet right and you know
aspirin famously thins the blood and the
idea that it was leaking into their
lungs is consistent with this so just to
to encapsulate this so far
um
thank you the
the question is if the initial
supposition is right that respiratory
pathogens tend not to be that serious
they tend not to be that virulent
um because in order to succeed they have
to keep you more or less on your feet
then what the heck happened with Spanish
flu that one was pretty damn virulent
and it had a very high case fatality
rate and now the question is could it
have been aspirin could it have been the
insanely high doses that were being
given at the time and the fear that
stoked people including doctors to use
and to prescribe these very very high
doses and when they weren't working to
amp them up the way we did with the
respirator pressures yeah the ventilator
ventilator pressures precisely and
apparently doctors
um military doctors were were early
early adopters of aspirin as treatment
and I
maybe there was some evidence some
places that what I've seen in my you
know relatively brief look so far is
that once you were on the aspirin is
going to be useful to treat Spanish Flu
Game uh at the point that your patients
started to get sicker the response was
almost always we'll give them more
aspirin which then actually accelerated
the demise of the patient yes and the
fact that this was happening in a
military context which is again very top
down right so you know whatever the high
ups are saying you know the high up
doctors in the military are saying
should be used is going to spread like
wildfire the point is that also Stokes
fear by giving the impression that it is
these young highly fit soldiers what the
heck kind of pathogen is this yes right
so the anomalies are
many surrounding 1918 and I would also
point out that just as you know every
death was counted as a coveted death
which amped our fear which caused us to
react with you know basically like a
panicked like a drowning person rather
than a rational person the idea that the
1918 flew was Haunting US during covet
fear of that flu caused us to behave
irrationally with respect to covid when
it emerged and frankly there's more
reason to be concerned about covid
because you know it's a you know it came
apparently from a lab but nonetheless it
does if either it's going to be able to
spread in which case it's going to abide
by at least some of the things that
limit the uh the the virulence of a
normal respiratory pathogen
and here we you know goes every bad
policy and mandated them from above
right and I think you you said it but um
iatrogenic causes of death and illness
will be a hundred percent conflatable
with the illness itself the pathogen
itself being the cause of death and
illness because iatrogenic harm only
comes when you go to the medical
establishment for treatment of the thing
and so of all the things that could
possibly be conflated this is this is
the easiest one to do and that you know
that doesn't mean that the conflation
was necessarily intentional right but if
a pathogen causes something and the
treatment of that something is far more
dangerous for you than the pathogen was
you you need to not be surprised at the
point that you have a hard time teasing
those two effects apart and the way to
tease those two effects apart is to look
at the different different Health Care
practices in places like New York versus
Delaware with regard to ventilators or
military bases versus cities with regard
to aspirin during Spanish flu right and
I think uh or you know or Sweden versus
uh yes I think I think Norway but I
don't know but Sweden versus some other
northern European country with regard to
effects of lockdowns and uh letting a
society be you know be as it is so you
know you look you look for the place
that did the different thing that you
think may have been causing the
iatrogenic harm and then you can begin
to see pattern and there will be those
who will say well
there's no RCT there's no randomized
control study on that randomized control
trial like of course there can't be
because that's not the way this research
could possibly work and that is not a
damning of the hypothesis or the
suggestion that it could be atrogenic
harm that is just the nature of the harm
that it causes you cannot do an RCT on
this so I will say before I was aware of
this argument on my last uh Joe Rogan
appearance I mentioned this possibility
I mentioned that I was in I was now
increasingly dwelling on the early use
of the ventilators
um and the fact that that would have
amped up the case the apparent case
fatality rate and caused us to react
ever more strongly and I worry that you
know in an environment
where behind the scenes
governmental authorities are actually
licensing themselves to let themselves
to shut down truth
right that they would also
um potentially who knows in what ways
they might be willing to cause panic in
order to get us to surrender
to their to their Authority yeah
there's just another couple of things
before we move on to our final segment
for today
um I as I said this paper is presented
as hypothesis it's got a lot of
suggestive suggestive evidence but I
looked at the I think it was a little
bit more than 100 papers that cite this
paper the starco 2009 paper that we've
been talking about and I find no
attempts successful or not just to
discredit it to discredit the argument
indeed I find and I you know I did not
look through all 100 papers at cited it
but a couple of the more recent papers
that site were interesting in different
ways
love it all in 2020
used the argument by starko about the
use of aspirin as the cause of so much
of the death and destruction of the
Spanish Flu as a cautionary tale this is
again in 2020 they use they accept as
fact what Starker lays out as aspirin
having been a considerable cause of the
death from Spanish flu and use that to
argue against the use of
hydroxychloroquine
without as far as I can tell any any
reason for doing that but they say ah
this can happen therefore this is
happening here okay so that I found
um interesting and then there's another
paper when in fact the study that caused
hydroxychloroquine to be
um dropped from the list of possible
treatments had the dose turned up so
high that in fact it did toxify people
this very safe drug was given in such
high doses that it caused this effect
which uh
certainly raises some questions yes why
why given that unlike aspirin in 1918
hydroxychloroquine has been on the
market has been in use for decades
already we know we know the the levels
you know not perfectly of course and it
will vary by individual but we have a
really good sense of what toxic levels
are so why would you have turned that
dial all the way up yep yeah and so then
there was another paper that cites um
again the starco 2009 paper which argues
that aspirin widespread use of aspirin
to treat Spanish Flu was actually the
cause of many of the deaths during the
Spanish flu epidemic
short at all in 2018 this is before
covid is a highly cited more much more
actually is more highly cited than the
original starco paper
article called Back to the Future
Lessons Learned From the 1918 influenza
pandemic and it's published in Frontiers
in cellular and infection microbiology
so I thought this was promising but
fascinatingly this paper completely
ignores her conclusions while citing her
and I've seen that happen many many
times right so they don't respond to the
arguments in her paper at all they
simply cite her to say that aspirin was
used as treatment during the Spanish Flu
and I have to wonder why so they
basically got in both of these two
papers that I've just said cite starco
2009 and again I went looking to see
okay this is hypothesis let me see if
anyone has tried to debunk it right to
falsify it right and on full display in
both of these papers that are some of
the most recent most cited papers that
cite her
you have this reductionist hubristic
approach to humans that doesn't
understand anything about complex
systems the complex system that is the
human body that is our immune system
that is human society and you know it's
standards gosh it's something we've been
saying over and over and over again
welcome to complex systems why aren't
the researchers including the doctors
and the scientists who are publishing in
these medical and scientific journals
and who are presumably therefore helping
to set policy for the next time
why can't they understand complex
systems why are they working with this
arrogance and this reductionist model
that will continue to destroy people
yes
um they're doing it well I don't know I
think what we really need is a is a body
that is capable of investigating the
question because you know we are
persistently left with uh multiple
possibilities is this some new kind of
hyper virulent incompetence something
that exceeds all previous examples of
incompetence or do we have something
worse than that because it's really hard
to Fathom how you could do this much
wrong and be this consistent about it
right it's hard for incompetent people
to pull that off
um but this was uh you know
potentially something else truly
impressive if it's incompetence yeah
it's really it's a stunning level of it
it's it's uh you know connoisseur level
some of the most competent incompetence
that I've ever seen very well said thank
you um I had two last points that I
wanted to make here one
um I was fascinated by this gatomalo
piece I also thought it was a very good
companion
for the piece that I wrote for unheard
boy I don't remember exactly when it was
but I wrote a piece about the question I
I had of course been about researching
biologist I handled many bats bare hands
um that was the way we handled them so
as not to injure them uh their wings are
very fragile
um and I had wondered at the point that
covet emerged I wondered well geez I was
handling wild bats and I you know
certainly took basic precautions but was
it possible that I was going to pick up
a virus
from a wild bat and I was going to be
patient zero in some massive pandemic
and I just got lucky and in considering
that question I realized that no in fact
I wasn't it's much harder for viruses to
LEAP from nature than we've been told we
have been sold a bill of goods that has
caused us to be much more frightened of
this possibility and in fact so
frightened that we apparently funded
research to study the viruses that we
thought or claimed or pretended could
have left out of Nature and then
turbocharged them to see what would
happen if they did right we this is a
self-inflicted wound and my point is no
I wasn't running a big risk of you know
spreading a pandemic by accident because
it's much harder for you know I could
have died of something but the point is
something in order to become a pandemic
has to LEAP into a person and then it
has to LEAP from person to person in
some way those are difficult
evolutionary steps for them to
accomplish so this is we talked about
this early on when we were first talking
about the possibility of lab leak back
in Spring of 2020 right the the the
rapid ability of this virus
um to move between people suggested that
it already had experience doing
something like that if not in people
than possibly in mink uh with uh what
was it the similar Ace II receptors
right uh mink uh human Airway tissue
humanized mice right all of these things
would have given at the training
essentially the lab playing the role of
the intermediate host which we've never
found because it probably doesn't exist
right um but anyway I thought okay so
gato Malo makes an excellent uh argument
that what happened is
um we spooked ourselves about a virus
that even though it is very destructive
was not likely to be that deadly by
virtue of the fact that it is a
respiratory virus and they abide by this
trade-off they have to if it had been a
super deadly virus it wouldn't have
spread around the world this way that's
right um so that's one point and then my
point is and we also got scared by a
bunch of
um ghost stories about how the next
virus was going to LEAP out of nature
any minute because humans are doing
something new and that's going to result
in some terrifying pandemic with an
extremely high fatality rate right also
not likely so those two things together
you know how how worried do we have to
be that a a virus is going to LEAP out
of Nature and have a huge case fatality
rate
um you know well if it's a respiratory
virus pretty low
um and pretty low for things to jump
between species when we're talking about
things like bird flu we're actually
talking about things that do jump
between species regularly not something
that jumped from nature that had never
been seen in people before
let me just pick up I know you have one
more point but you said um with regard
to you know could you have were you
likely to become patient zero uh in in a
pandemic
um that you could have picked up from a
bat and then spread and you had a little
um asterisk there and said well you know
I could have gotten sick like I could
have come down with something and of
course you know one of your mentors
um did exactly that I believe no we
don't know what she died oh okay
um but but biologists do
um especially not so much with the kinds
of bats that you were working on because
you were working on making bats and you
weren't anywhere near caves right but
you know if you know bats do
um have respiratory viruses and being in
a cave where the air is famously not
refreshed and
um and is
um and a person working in a cave with a
bunch of bats
um May well pick up something well they
do it's not viruses the thing that um
that bad biologists sometimes get is
histoplasmosis which is a fungus
um but yes but it's but it's basically
another reason you know like should you
if the bats weren't in the cave you know
she'd be spending time in the cave or
outside of the cave you're better off
with regard to keeping clear of
respiratory infections being in fresh
air outside moving around right where
where there's a lot of airflow and you
know not in a you know a cave or a room
or care home or you know something else
where uh where whatever is floating
around you're probably going to inhale
it at some point yep yep no from the
point of view of you know there are
these three miners who appear to have
picked up something uh cove-like prior
to the ancestor of SARS cov2 potentially
having been taken into the lab in Wuhan
um who died of it but they didn't
transmit it to anybody right and frankly
the exposure level needed for them to
get sick was apparently incredibly high
they were working uh taking guano out of
an old mine and so the point is they
were you know knee-deep in a highly
Dusty destructive environment the lungs
they picked up this disease and did not
transmit it right so the point is
getting something from nature is
possible transmitting it is unlikely to
other people unless there's some path
for that to happen Okay the last point I
wanted to make is we have said here
we have bridled when people have accused
us of uh
quote unquote killing people by
discussing reasons to be concerned about
things like the safety of mRNA
transfection agents
which makes no sense at multiple levels
for one thing nobody seems particularly
eager to give us credit for having saved
people given that these transfection
agents appear to be dangerous right they
don't want to give us any credit they
just want to say you're killing people
by raising hesitancy when in fact
hesitancy may have been life-saving but
my point is I don't want credit for
saving people I don't want to be accused
of killing people I want the recognition
that the conversation saves people that
you can disagree with us and you may be
wrong and we may be right that doesn't
make us the Lifesavers and you The
Killers the point is and honest
participation in a conversation about
what is true amongst people who have
something reasonable to contribute
everybody is contributing to the thing
that saves lives right
on the flip side
were you a governmental official who
decided that it would be okay to pollute
the stream of information by pretending
that people who have died from uh abuse
of a ventilator are actually deaths due
to covid right pretending that a death
of you know a child is equivalent to the
death of somebody in their 80s people
who have not only polluted the
information stream but son saw fit to
silence those who were trying to unspin
their story right those people actually
did Kill folks right they were not
participating in a collective effort to
figure out what was true so that we
could lose fewer lives so that we could
you know protect people who were in a
position to be protected they did
exactly the opposite they blinded us
that's what they did they intentionally
blinded us and then they demonized Us by
claiming that even if we were saying
true things if they went in the
direction making you distrust vaccines
or your government for mandating them
that you were a terrorist right that is
the kind of diabolical stuff that we
have been dealing with and it is time
for everybody to wake up a government
that could do that to you cannot be
trusted and it must be cleared of people
who participated in that and it must be
restored to protecting the basic
principles that still apply as much as
they did when the founders outlined them
foreign
[Music]